hello so um I'm going to be introducing
Alexander Endor for this talk um so
Alexander hendor is responsible for data
and artificial intelligence at the bount
consultancy H in Germany he has many
years many years of experience in the
practical application introduction and
communication of data and AI driven
strategy and decision making processes
through through his commitment as
speaker and chair of various
International conferences such as Pon
Kai de Pond data B he has approv an
expert in the field of data data
intelligence he's been appointed python
software foundation and Euro python
fellows for this very for his various
contributions and yeah so this talk is
about 10 years of community
organizer yeah thanks for the
introduction VOR uh yeah good morning
everyone uh I'm fro to be here speaking
to thanks thanks for joining this talk
uh it's great to be here at high New
York uh in this talk I'm want to give
you like a deep dive into uh my
community experience of the P 10 years
yeah it's unbelievable how fast 10 years
can go by in the community and I'm going
to want to give you like an overview
want to give like hey what was my story
and what can you learn from my story or
what I did I learned on that journey and
I want to share with you um and uh there
of like a big part of uh leadership
leadership in communities how to manage
communities how can you help listen help
other people thrive enable other people
but also probably learn to listen to
other people and um yeah so balance
ideas motivations and get this amazing
Community going which is I think still
very fascinating
uh so um we're also going to look into
some of the boring stuff like
Administration finances because you know
there's like conference there build
bills to be paid the reimbursements to
be made and and of
course larger events have a certain
level of complexity that needs to be
addressed and I'm really excited to
share my personal story here with you on
my journey in the python and Pata
communities and I hope you can something
from my talk and I'm also give you like
some sise we working on europython and
thoughts we think we also need to
improve uh the python community in on
the future
so this doesn't work
so okay no okay it's just slow sorry I
was just impatient so okay this is me uh
you can find me Linkin these are some
links on uh uh organizations I've been
working with
contributed and this is this is my
company Cur week we have a partner we
have Boutique consultancy and focused on
targeted Innovation and transformation
so this is my day job and uh in uh well
today I don't want to talk about my day
job at the experience here building data
strategies and implementation with open
open source in large Enterprises uh
today I want to talk about on my way
into the community and take you on this
journey so how did I end up here giving
this talk so um let me start in the
early 1910 so the early oh no sorry
sorry just off by Century no problem in
the early n 20110 there were like many
fre things going on in the tech World
there was like data science like a new
frontier dealing with data like big data
I mean Big Data was probably the medi
the most dominant they were all like
these machine learning was becoming a
thing um then there were like also like
MCH machine learning basically for the
masses with like tools like tensil flow
uh the rise of python Jupiter notebooks
and apart from python there was also
JavaScript JavaScript was suddenly back
from the dead with no JS and JavaScript
was a big thing and and so in and also
in the data space there was not only
like the the the data tools we know from
from libraries there was also like this
whole no sequel no SQL or not only SQL
Revolution going on with databases like
mongod Cassandra and many many others
like document databases and no SQL which
was like coin samee time at the time and
where was I at that time actually and
basically there's now me in the middle
of all this and my job is working in the
digital music distribution so working
with apple working with Spotify digital
downloads streaming has just like
started to be a thing there and I saw
like the music industry that's why fun
fact it's really good to give this talk
actually in a in a room that called
Music Hall like that's really nice
coincidence uh because there's a
actually like a strong background here
and and so I was in the middle of the
probably the first industry the music
industry was the first industry was
which was fully digitalized yeah so it's
a tiny industry with a lot of attention
but it was like the first to be like
fully digital so and I I knew I had to
upgrade my tool set at that time because
the tools we've been working for years
did no longer give me a service they
gave me more more headaches than making
me more efficient so I said okay I need
another programming language I need
other tools for for data for analytics I
always liked working with data so uh so
I have a lot of uh questions to answer
for example okay what about should I use
another database for like web scraping
and getting other data in um like mongod
TV or Cassandra which program language
python or Java Java was way cooler than
python yeah it was like yeah that was a
new JavaScript framework like every hour
and yeah so I had to make a lot of
decisions and of course there were all
my weekends I spent on course era
learning data science machine learning
all these neutral cool things and it was
also like I think a new era in um very
accessible education like cause error
courses at the time because all this was
freely available even like from Elite
university courses on data science where
available but it was like a quite busy
time if I look in retrospect so actually
I choose mongodb for like working for
databases and I decided to go for python
which I never regretted um so my first
pyth conference was python de which was
like the this is the German conference
at the time at the time probably like a
4 500 people in this events still
because Java was still like the dominant
language C C++ whatever python was
around but not super popular then and so
I started to attend my first conference
and um yeah and from there it took me
further so um my way into the community
was like after that conference in 2013 I
attended euryon in Berlin and euryon is
like the European gathering of the
Python Community as an attendee so here
you see the BCC in Berlin now you see
like it's a great conference somewhere
in this picture over there this is me
there was a keynote by Travis all ofan
you also see n Focus the old Focus logo
over there on the on the slide with Mike
my co-chair like and the softw fan on
stage so I intended
that and also I decided to volunteer
actually so I I'm around I don't know
anybody so they had like this open
volunteer system so I just signed up as
a session chair actually yes so and the
people I actually was session sharing uh
were like close friends now um and so
and I jumped over my Shadow going into a
Bavarian BR house like a Bavarian
Brewery in Berlin because if you know
Bavarian BR house is in south southern
German villain is very North and
actually they used to be Arch enemies so
this is something like we just said okay
this is kind of contradiction this is a
very touristy thing to do but these
people I work with now to the Bros they
look nice though let's join them and
actually we had great conversations
there so I met in O from high to London
I met vincon vam who's now the Spacey um
like great people and we had like very
open discussions about what was going on
and yeah so it was actually like I just
stepped into the community and and then
there was also like this European
society meeting like the from and I said
okay membership is free why not join so
I um attended the assembly and ended up
signing up as an auditor because nobody
was there was no candidate for Auditors
so Auditors like hey checking the
invoices is it like paid for the purpose
and all the stuff so right it's an easy
task I I know that from other um
nonprofits I have worked before like
rebuilding a local Pride organization uh
when it had fallen apart so I like okay
this is like two day two two hours of
work I can do that and I didn't not know
where this decision would basically
finally take me and there was this
satellite event p in 2014 here you see
uh it was like you know Le's also
outside uh see you see like people like
the first James James is there on the
podium uh James Paul you just saw in the
opening so this was like the first P
data in Continental Europe just after P
data London um and I was just there at
an attendee I had found out okay there
is this data conference that looks like
interesting let's just like join it and
I did not know where just attending this
P data would finally take me
so so let me just
introduce what I did in the past 10
years a bit
so as I on the upper left you see well
let's start with down there um I also
was in the in the mongodb community they
did a lot of community work back in the
days I founded the local Meetup and
eventually 2016 became Mongol Master uh
yeah spoke also in New York City at
mongod world or mongodb but let's focus
on python so um so I joined EUR python
as an auditor and then I was any new
people I was on mailing list and your
Pon was rebuilding for the B conference
in 2015 it was also like this an
organizational change happening and so
finally I ended I ended up being program
chair of a conference in the B working
with strangers I've never met on email
organizing a major conference this like
one of the fascinating things in the
python community and I said okay this
can never work but hey why not let's do
this um so I was program chair for your
for 5 years um also served as a board
member for 2 years then at europ pyen
people approached me hey what about the
German conference bringing this local to
the area where live I said do you want
to join the team I said yeah sure why
not so I joined the p on the E team was
program chair conference chair and then
we moved to to Berlin and join forces
with P berin so we we actually merge
Pyon and py data in Berlin to one large
conference because we believe also
believe that
also data scientists need to learn to
program as we just like learned in sum
keynote as well um and yeah and from
there and it was also like your scipi I
think many of you know scipi in Austin
so there's also a EUR scipi I just
started helping a bit and ended up why
we program shair for two years today I'm
focusing on finance and admin so um and
of course the the community work was
also contributed like uh I recognized so
I became python software Foundation
fellow and a EUR python fellow later um
and but one important decision which I
want to point out is was joining the
pyth soft forment as a chair because I
saw a lot with like Community organizing
what also can go wrong and where a
faults and where we waste probably waste
volunteers Time by not the best
organization and back office services
around so I decided okay there's a need
for Change and from my background
because my first first background was
actually I studied the law and then was
part of a music startup back in the days
and and so I also have like um build
like business build up business Affairs
know a little bit of a contract and
stuff and said okay we need to be better
at this stuff but this is something
unique I can also add to to the
community by all this background
knowledge from a totally different angle
than than programing so I decided to
join the German python software
Association and say okay let's get
better let's rebuild for proper
organization and stuff yeah so some of
the I also want to join tell show you
some of the enjoyable results here so
this is like how Europe python looks
there some somewhere me in the middle is
like last year Europe python you see
this like just like as P dat here it's
like very volunteer driven and very open
diverse um Community this is p suest
which I just didn't mention because it's
just like the local meta but we just
like a few weeks ago ago we had enus
here from from from Spacey and had like
a big lecture hall in heidleberg
University and uh this is like working
this and this is like current Pon P bin
um here on the BCC bin again like this
is just like taken from last year's
conference
so so now you know a little bit my story
so of course I think people reached out
to me because I I probably wasn't bad at
what I was doing so people always asked
me hey you want to join a team you want
to help and I I sometimes it's hard to
say yes because if I want to point back
here actually I'm I managed to to leave
europython for two years but after
Corona europython the team had changed
and and they asked me hey can you can
you come back and help again with
program and I saw like oh the the team
did a great job and really made a change
I was actually looking for like like I
wanted for many years at europ P to
happen and they actually made it so they
built like a great Community during co
co there I said okay well yes I have
this other conference already but yes
and currently I'm also like a sitting
board member there and we working on
very similar reasons the very similar
topics Administration better making
things better for the community there
so in the first part if you who's who
has ever contributed to python pyata or
Pyon even as a volunteer so who knows of
it yeah okay yeah so so I think why is
it so important the the community is
organizing these events so but I think
it's one of our success factors actually
because we have a large very active and
I cannot emphasize this enough welcoming
community so if you if I go to other
conferences or other organizations you
just go there and if you don't know
anyone you will not get to know anyone
in the python Community you basically
join and everybody say hey come on let's
give a hug let's talk let's join the
community I think that's one one of the
most amazing things there and because
our content is Community Driven it's
Community selected it's very authentic
so I've hardly seen any bad talk which
was just like a sales page or something
non adding extra value at these events
and apart from the program and the talks
we see at here I think it's also very
important we have diverse and inclusive
teams working on the GRS program
understand the needs of people who apply
to the GRS program and basically it's
it's it's not just like set up like if
you look at other events they say okay
let's run a huge event you hire people
event experts for like running events
but they don't know anything about the
content and and you end up like totally
different thing yeah um so and I think
there's a really strong because this
everything we do is very authentic and
real and and it's pragmatic and it's
it's it's it's it's really driven by hey
how can we really help everyone to get
here how can we help people to learn and
include them in community but also how
can we provide like really topnotch
talks about the latest stuff that is
just going on so these events are for
everybody I would always like to phrase
it this is like a conference run by
experts for other experts and a little
footnote or aspiring expert experts to
be because we're inclusive and also very
welcoming to newcomers and we have a
strong focus on um the attending
experience so it's not just you you pay
your ticket you get it here so like hey
how can you make this enjoyable how can
you make this interactive how can you
also help people to get to know other
people because also we aware of many
people are like first time you attend
the conference there's imposter syndrome
yeah you know a poster syndrome yeah you
you go into conference and compare your
knowledge with the knowledge of a large
expert group and I think nobody can win
that not even a Nobel Prize winner can
win that yeah so um so uh so we we we
have like help people to open up like
hey join have conversations with others
uh learn by talk to to other people and
we have a strong focus on diversity and
inclusion and we spend a lot of time
thinking about it and and reaching out
and and make it make it like a good
experience
so how do these conference actually work
yeah so like it's it is like like a
general pattern because there there are
differences from organization and
Conference to conference but this is
like the I think like the the general
overview so the conferences are
volunteer committees that organize
multiple parts of a conference so
there's there's a program committee
working on the program selection to call
for proposals working with the viev
viewers just making um a selection then
there is a diversity diversity outreach
program a grand program to make the
conference more accessible for students
like we produce this produce not only
ruce tickets has also a grant program
which is generously also mostly
supported by the python software
Foundation or the European Society on on
Focus who actually give an extra budget
to say okay we can help people with
travel and getting tickets so if you
cannot afford it um so and of course
Outreach Outreach is very important
working with other communities so we
very closely work with P ladies to say
how can we make the
conference a great experience also for
women in tech for have P ladies there
with panels program a table and
everything and of course have a code of
conduct and look do we need to update
anything on the code of conduct so we
half bike and jeda setup so we have like
a good experience and a respectful
environment for everyone attending so
then there's the video recording which
is also like a very important part
because people we publish these videos
just like this video being recorded we
publish this on the YouTube channel of P
data and other people learn from that
and it's not just a theory because or
because I know I watch these talks
actually one of the coolest experience
was just last year we were I was with a
colleague on the train to the in and we
were talking about a conference and
somebody was just sitting opposite to us
and said what are you talking about
unnoticed and I said yeah yeah we're
going to Pon P building we're part of
the organization committee and he said
yeah hi I'm I'm from Nigeria I watch
these videos on YouTube and actually
they they helped me become a machine
learning engineer now I'm working in
Germany so this was like the best proof
I ever had okay this is not just like a
theoretic thing inside the community it
really helps also like others to find
and educate find the way into the
community educate themselves on the
everything we do which was like this was
quite reming yeah so of course we have
communication website onsite volunteers
session chairs like um design swar
handling out swag handling out badges
which is what onti volunteer driven of
course and there's conference CH so
there are like multiple communties
working together on focusing on one
making one part of the conference
happen this is all volunteers this is
all in their free time not being paid
just that contributing free time to the
cost so and then there's organizers so
organizers are in these committees and
what do organizers actually do so let me
like there's no like
official definition of what an organizer
actually is so this is my definition the
best I came up with like a volunteer
that takes on more responsibility in
workn so somebody who is more like not
just like for example like somebody
helping on site is hey you you volunteer
on the sport for a specific task and
organize like organizers are more
responsible for a specific part of the
conference they work as a team they
coordinate with other organizers or
committees so for example program and
video of course has to work close
together because the program is actually
being recorded um you have to you have
to coordinate you have to uh do a lot of
uh project management you have to
monitor M manage MTH Stones uh so uh
yeah it this sounds like work like uh
because it's actually also work and you
have to follow existing processes and
guidelines but also rethink them okay is
there also things we need to innovate
change or add to this so we're in a
constant Innovation circle like when we
building conferences we okay there was a
learning from last year and we take this
on for the to the next year and
constantly um involved so it's not
like conference guidelines from 10 years
ago are probably not like totally
different but there's a lot of
innovation uh happened in the past 10
years and to make it a better um to make
it better for everyone so what do
volunteers do just as I mentioned
volunteer help on specific task I would
argue most volunteers are on side that
but for example reviewers in the program
committee who are just just doing
reviews um uh uh to help like to make
the program committee can make up its
mind on what to select on uh it's more
like small and defined work packages
most outside um and that's volunteers so
but there's also organizations so what
do organizations do because an event
like this or like a large conference in
the it needs an entity uh that actually
is responsible for like all the legal
stuff St uh the legal entity like
running the conference somebody has to
sign this contract with the venue which
includes a prepayment
guarantees and um take care of
administration sponsoring legal
insurance tax and there's organizations
like the python software Foundation now
focus of course for this event the
python software forand in Germany for
Pon the data bu on indur scipi um
there's Financial stuff to be sorted out
reimbursements to be made for financial
great um Grand applicants and provide
processes and guidelines and structure
this conference can happen and also
navigate risk and budget because of
course in the past years we probably
lived in the in the in a Land of Plenty
because like Tech data AI was growing we
were just like a part of it but we also
have to prepare okay what
if people if these companies scale down
as we experienc last year when Facebook
like released a lot of people and not
just like grow grow grow forever and we
have to navigate this as well
now and Magic what's Magic I think magic
is just like um the thing that happens
like these like
strangers meet and build committees and
build it like these amazing things like
this so this is like another ingredient
I just want to mention I don't have an
explanation for it so um there's also
like challenges opportunities there so
one challenge is the decentralized
nature so what do I mean with
decentralized
nature the initiative often depends on
very few people really driving it so hey
let's do it let bring Pyon D 2017 to
Carro it was just like two people at L
Yonder said oh let's let's apply for
this let's do it and let's bring other
people on board um so U but then of
course um it's decentralized we
basically mostly run on Google Drives
and documentation and teams constantly
change very often so even if there's
documentation it's probably unknown or
it's lost um or it's maybe not
documented because of course everybody's
very busy tired we have meetting to
committee meetings ear the evening so
sometimes you probably do not the best
documentation at 9:00 p.m. when you say
okay finally my day is over and let's
I'll do this tomorrow and eventually you
don't um but of course due to the
centralized nature and not everything's
documented or it's like many people and
actors in these Community change over
time which I think it's it's a good
thing because it constantly brings a new
blood new ideas so it's not like the
same routines everyone but the downside
is very often it's reinvent involves
like Reinventing the wheel repeating
mistakes or applying like have redundant
setups also like for technical stuff so
so that's one CH and then I think one of
the major challenges is indidual
workload for a few sometimes and I think
that's the most important part that
needs to be managed um to help to run a
healthy uh conference and community so
like the workload has to be balanced of
course you can have like a con
conference run with like very few people
with like heavy workload because of
course small teams are great a small
team can Co coordin it really fast yeah
but of course it has to handle like a
lot of workload as well so probably like
large teams is not like the best
solution yeah so like rumor says Apple
has like these small teams with five
people and sorry Microsoft thanks for
hosting but they all say like Microsoft
had these like large teams and that was
Microsoft was slower in the past I read
that somewhere um but thanks again
forting microsof um so uh so but yeah so
but the aftermath is that people you
have like really successful event on the
outside like the the audience is
cheering great event everything was
smooth and people basically the day
after the conference they burn out
ghosts leave said okay this like one
time experience only and then they leave
and we have to do to do better there
because often these things are they they
they happen of course backstage um and
and it's also not hard to be an
organizer and complain to the audience
yeah it was great for you but I had a
really bad time in the closing session
you don't want to act like that but it
happened um sometimes also crisis like
to be honest like the first building
conference after Corona was very hard
for me I I think I have a big fur but I
was sick for one day I was stress SI
after a conference one day because we
had to navigate a conference 10 days
after all Corona measurements had been
like were like stopped just 10 days
before the conference which gave us a
lot of things to to think and to work
with so um yeah and and of course uh you
also have to take in account many people
like to join committees especially
program committees always like like
sounds prestigious you it's easy to find
people for that but you probably and
also have to put it like um not everyone
is as reliable as you
probably uh expect or they don't see the
the the reason to be relied because they
also like have a different impression
what what's what's there and how
important it is to be reliable and not
say oh I cannot make this meeting I will
make it next time and then it's like
happening five four times times in a row
and this can be really toxic for a team
which is working working hard and
there's always like people like the Free
Riders yeah and probably not on purpose
but maybe also on purpose but it's it's
it's not really good for a team so I
think like for having like a good
organization like a good Community like
the best communties I've always seen
have like a really good team leader or
two team leaders who are also able to
say hey it's your volunteer it's totally
fine to say say I have to leave I have
things in my life that came up but just
not always pretend to be there and you
don't yeah just like it's totally okay
sorry something came up I have to go and
not having other keeping others like in
hanging in the loop forever um because
people also want to distribute and say
let's do this together and assign task
not just to get rid of the work also to
include hey we doing this together as a
team so I think good leadership and team
management is like people to running uh
good conference um committees and yeah
then one really bad thing with events is
um prob it's different to software
development where you can always have
like a good reason yeah release date is
delayed we have to delay some stuff
because it's just like software the bad
thing with events is you have a day to
sell tickets and the door will open no
matter what so keeping the Milestones
like keeping everything in time is also
like very important to manage uh because
you otherwise things will just pile up
to the very end and this and and and and
working on all that will be like really
stressful yeah and so and of course
there's many diverse people like with
many different backgrounds and ideas
working in these committees so but it's
also really important to manage ideas
and to learn how to respectfully manage
ideas
and um and uh the um expectations so new
ideas are very important yeah but the
Comm the community is very dedicated to
other people's needs so but there also
can be too many ideas and also you have
to be like it's also like again
communication required you find a lot of
people joining in committees throwing
their ideas what other people could do
there that's like common I've seen this
in many communi ities political parties
you will never lack of people like
having good ideas for you but it's very
important to say learn to say no or
require action plan or yeah what's the
action plan who's up for this task and
and who's actually responsible like
because yeah thanks for your idea uh but
we also need to make this happen yeah
and also I I saw like a certain tendency
of course we're all Engineers Engineers
mindsets of course we have we tend to
perfectionism and the same perfectionism
is the is is the enemy of the good so
sometimes good is just like good enough
yeah also because like making like these
extra 5% can can require like maybe
double the workload or stuff like that
sometimes yeah it's also it's okay to
let go from time to time on the
understand the Perfection astion and of
course all this involves a lot of
communication um and of course
administrational processes so how could
you describe like an event like um Pyon
event which is basically a one year
event yearly event so and it's very
often overseen and neglected that
Administration processes yeah if they if
they run smoothly it can be a good
experience for everyone but if they
don't run smoothly yeah there's a lot of
like to be cleaned up and it's very
often overlooked how much things are
happening in the background there's
hundreds and probably thousands of
tickets sold invoices invoices sometimes
need to be Rewritten
um you need to file tax especially
European Union is very en joyful because
we have different V in every European
country although we have the European
Union and of course every European
country has own tax regulations how to
file vat and all the stuff like V Sal
tax um and there's there's a lot of work
to be done of course if you have like
the proper processes set up in the first
place this can run smoothly but if it
doesn't it has it can be a lot of work
to clean up
um and and yeah and I believe this is
why I basically remember I said I it was
a deliberate decision also to join the
German software Association because I
saw um I saw failure also in
organization and I I I I realized it's
totally unfair to us volunteers to
contribute free time and basically screw
up like paying reimbursements or
sometimes a volunteer orderers something
on behalf of an organization and
reminders um ended up in their private
email boxes and I think this is a really
bad experience and this had to be fixed
so we fix it with like providing better
processes um and because we don't want
to drive people out like thanks for
volunteering but we also give you like a
lot of trouble I think that's a bad
proposal so for example we totally fixed
that in Germany and also like streamline
tasks and uh like really can enable an
organization was like hey this is the
process this is we work this is like the
this is like the time frame to expect
like for reimbursements 2 weeks after
the conference like giving like
everybody like um clear dates one is
what is going to happen and also but
also make it happen that date because
otherwise people will just throw you a
lot of more communication hey I'm
waiting for this and somebody has to
answer that and so of course I'm German
so everything has to work like clockwork
so it's very important it works like
clockwork or like as good as as as good
as you can get and also likely
transparent what's happening in these
processes um and yeah it's as I like
this is a year many of these events in
the community are yearly events so it's
like a popup company or a popup store
you basically set it up for one one year
and and then it has to work and uh so
year conference is like very often
europython we have the problem EUR the
EUR Society with have things to do than
the conference but eventually when the
conference comes closer it's sucks up
all the attention and the energy and it
results in a high workload of board
members so um so we realized okay
there's a requirement we can
professionalize Outsource stuff but then
of course as a volunteer organization
with volunteer board members we said
okay who's who's the boss like who even
signed up this board to be a boss of
somebody or like yeah so um yeah and
then we have to also like rethink legal
structur so there's a huge conference we
only have the EUR society which is like
the heart yeah and what what if the
conference totally goes south for some
reasons we probably don't control we
probably should have like a legal entity
like also like shielding Europe Society
from that and yeah we hardly have any
lawyers or people who in in the
community who can fix that but we need
to address it and start working on it
there because we we also like your
python I mean we well funded from the
conference
and but these funds are not just coming
from somewhere because we have donors so
no this is this is money we have at our
disposal because a lot of people
contributing feel free time so I feel or
we feel like very responsible how to
handle these funds because it's not just
other people's money it's Community
money so we have to be act like super
responsible for them so and also having
all this consistency over the years is
also like really hard
so yeah think I like far so like yeah
skills that's a good thing like skills
what skills do we need to run these
conferences um so the good thing is many
talents are well many skills are needed
there's a technical domain expertise in
the domain but as of communication
leadership teamwork um giving and
receiving constructive con criticism is
one of the um skills you need uh and uh
and what you don't need that's why
crosss like solo missions or endless
fighting for own ideas this is something
which is not really helping the the good
thing is you don't need to have like
okay this is the checklist and I can
join if I can do everything I can
because the community is really great
and it how will help you grow on these
different
tasks so um then there's committees
there's many committees you can
contribute to and say okay I'm also have
like like design why not join them
uh I Al skipped it a bit because I'm bit
short of time so let me close with like
my final thoughts and future perspective
here so um Community has grown a lot and
it's still growing yeah especially after
the pandemic we see yes we have like a
little pause there but it's still
thriving um we have to optimize further
um to help others Thrive and our culture
also could enable other Tech compan
communities because what we have is very
unique to the python Community as far as
I
know so so first thing we need platforms
to thrive so we need platforms that can
optimize and handle growth on a high
level like and also like he help us keep
like the high level we have at these
conference so basically a lot of again
is back office administration project
management um sharing experience
mentoring Lo dealing with local
requirements um Finance Tax or you can
put it like all the boring stuff yeah um
but also like have consistence
replicable uh um processes governance
and documentation for example like a
grand program also needs certain
framework of governance we say who do we
want to fund because very often this
this the decisions are just like made by
by a committee without guidelines I'm
not saying they make wrong decisions but
I think it's better to put like in a
certain guidelines and framework like
give governance this is like people we
want to fund all this is these are like
probably groups we don't want to fund
yeah um for because they don't probably
don't need it like whatever um there's
there's there needs to be more
governance and guidelines in writing and
and only like a St stable Platforms in
the background can can provide this with
Ever Changing teams over time like to to
keep it like consistent um uh for the
community and also like mentoring and
having like a network of people in the
past so governance yeah I I I covered
that basically already yeah um and also
like division yeah why not offer this
also like to other Tech communities
because there's a lot of like envelops
communities like even like non
non-programming communities you could
like see blue energy like there's like a
lot of things so I think the culture we
have established here can really help
other Technologies also Thrive and I
think it would be great just to say hey
we're here and if you want to work like
that you're welcome and we're happy to
help
so so enabling future organizers yeah um
is actually yeah we're doing great but
we still can do better that's it's like
and all that together like i' I've
thought a lot as you see I think a lot
about Community how communities can be
better I'm a proud member of python and
pataa communities but I also thought
okay can we take this further so I'm
also like happy to announce Pioneers H
that's a nonprofit I'm just like in the
founding phase and process to actually
say hey enable Tech communities
providing stable back office from
everything um I've learned um in the
python community and providing mentoring
governance healthy heal and help
building Healthy Communities all others
and also of course interact with our
community because I think the best thing
of python Community is always like uh
the cross polination yeah there's a web
developer talking to an
astronomer yeah having different
perspectives and finding magic Solutions
because they have like um multiple
backgrounds so yeah well it's going to
launch in January I'm I'm really proud
to do that was not an easy decision
because you see from my community work I
have a lot of un played already but I
said hey this is I decided this is
something unique I can I can also
provide and bring to the table for the
community given my also business and
legal background and um so I said yeah
let's give it a goal um yeah and yeah
thanks thanks for attending the talk uh
[Applause]
yeah